في ضوء اعلان حاله الطوارئ في مدينه
تايلاند في ولايه جورجيا الامريكيه حضرت
السفاره السعوديه في واشنطن رعاياها من
الاقتراب من مناطق الاحتجاجات واتباع ما
تصدره الجهات المختصه من تعليمات السلامه
الامريكيه الى اعمال عنف لفتره وجيزه يوم
امس السبت حيث اشعل متظاهرنا النار في
سياره للشرطه وحطم ونوافذ مباني
[موسيقى]
ونبقى ايضا في امريكا التي تشهد المزيد من
اعمال العنف المسلح راح ضحيتها المئات
خلال اول 29 يوما فقط من العام الجاريه
2023 زميل سالم راجح يعطينا بعضا من ارقام
العنف الذي تعيشه او عاشته عده ولايات
امريكيه في الايام الاخيره
هل امريكا امنه السؤال الابرز هذه الايام
بعد مقتل المبتعث السعودي الوليد الغريبي
على يد مواطنه امريكيه في ولايه بنسلفانيا
هذا السؤال قادنا الى البحث عن جرائم
العنف بالاسلحه في الولايات المتحده في
اول 25 يوما من العام الجاري 20 23 سجلت
39 حاله اطلاق نار في عموم الولايات وفقا
لموقعي ارشيف العنف المسلح الذي كشف ايضا
عن تسجيل
1400 وفاه بالاسلحه منذ مطلع العام الجاري
واكثر من 2400 اصابه اضافه الى
1850 حاله انتحار عدد كبير من الاطفال
ذهبوا ضحيه هذا العنف في الاسابيع الاربعه
الاولى من العام الجاري 20 30 وفقا للموقع
حيث يلقى 55
دون ال 11
مصرعهم نتيجه استخدام الاسلحه في اعمال
عنف في 18 ولايه امريكيه فضلا عن المصابين
هذه الارقام مشاهدينا مرشحه للزياده خلال
عرضي هذه الفقره من مدينته ويسترن
الامريكيه ينضم الينا الباخت في الشؤون
الامريكي احمد الحمدي سيد احمد اهلا وسهلا
بك معي في نشره الاخبار
ارقام كبيره 39 حاله اطلاق نار 1400 في
اول شهر من السنه فقط في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
ما الذي يحدث في امريكا هلا امريكا
يعني بغرض تحقيق منافع يعني تجاره ممنوعات
او سطو بانواعه هذا النوع من الاجرام
ليس منتشرا في امريكا اكثر من الدول
المثيله يعني من المعدلات متقاربه في
الدول المتماثله بامريكا ليست حاله خاصه
ولكن لدينا نوع اخر من العنف يعني لا ادري
كيف يمكن تسميته ربما ينتج عن الانفجار
العواطف سواء كانت بغرض الانتقام او بغرض
المشكله نفسيه معينه او مشكله عمليه
احيانا يعني ضد زملائها العمل تحدث هؤلاء
الافراد عاده غير معتدين للاجرام ولكنه
يتعرضون لظروف معينه يعني تؤدي الى حاله
الانفجار هذه المشكله التي تواجه امريكا
لانه هذه الفئه تستطيع الوصول للسلاح في
امريكا بسهوله كبيره جدا مقارنه بغالبيه
الدول العالم وهذه يعني الحوادث اللي
معدلاتها عاليه في امريكا اوتوماته
المشكله حقيقيه يعني تجعل امريكا يمكن ان
تصنف بانها غير امنه مقارنه بالدول
المماثله ان نتحدث عن ولا معينه ام ان
الامر يشمل كل الولايات الموجوده في في
الولايات المتحده اليوم
بالنسبه للنوع الاول الاجرام من معتدي
الاج
رام تم محصور في مناطق يعني هو في جميع
الولايات ولكنه في مناطق معينه داخل المدن
يعني هناك احياء معينه معروفه انها يعني
العصابات تمارس فيها نشاط عالي سواء في
تجاره المخدرات او اي تجاره اي شيء ممنوع
وعاده تكون في الجرائم مع ثلاثه الجرائم
فيها مرتفعه وغالبيه هذه الجرائم تكون بين
المجرمين وبينهم البعض سواء صراعات على
النفوذ وشابه ولكنه بالنسبه للنوع الثاني
من الجراء اللي هو يعني
الجرائم العاطفيه هذه لا هذه موزع في كل
مكان تحدث في كل مكان لا يوجد استثناء
يعني حتى الاماكن
همم في كل مدينه اما اما سبقا حدثت فيها
حادثه في نفس المدينه او في منطقه قريبه
جدا منها
بالتالي اليوم كيف تتعامل الاداره
الامريكيه هل هناك بالشعور بحاله من القلق
تستوجب تحرك يعني اقوى في التعامل مع كاد
التصاعد في ارقام حالات العنف والعنف
المجتمع الموجود الان في الولايات المتحده
في هذا المجال لانه نقطه صراع سياسي بين
تيارات مختلفه يعني هناك التيار مدعوم من
همم يعني من دلوبي مصنعيش سلاح يمنع
التحرك اضافه الى وجود تاييد شعبي يعني
ثقافه امتلاك السلاح لاسباب مختلفه ثقافه
متاصل لدى الشعب الامريكي لذلك هناك في لا
باس بها من المواطنين يرون ان حريه الوصول
للسلاح اساسي للمواطن لا يجب المساس به
لذلك هناك مقاومه عاليه للتحركات في هذا
الاتجاه لذلك يعني راينا انه لمده 30 سنه
لم يصدر اي قانون يقيد باي درجه من
التقييد العمليه التداول الاسلحه وحملها
باستثناء قانون يعتبر يعني خطوه صغيره جدا
في هذا الاتجاه الصدر العام الماضي طيب
سيد احمد انت من خلال مركبتك اليوم نتحدث
عن تصاعد في جرائم معينه نتحدث عن التطرف
مثلا عن كراهيه عن
مع استهداف
للاجانب هل هناك تميز بين الارقام
والسؤال الاخير ايدك كيف نجحت مثل هذه
الحوادث الان اذا وصفناها بحوادث ارهاب
محليه كما يرى البعض يعني كيف يعني نجحت
في بسط سيطرتها ربما وهيمنتها بهذا الشكل
في في في كثير من المناطق الولايات في
امريكا
اكبر من هذه الحوادث حوادث عشوائيه طبعا
هناك حوادث كراهيه هناك حوادث انتقامه
هناك حوادث يعني عن العنصريه سواء كانت ضد
الاقليات ضد المهاجرين او حتى ضد بعض
الفئات الدينيه ولكن هذه الحوادث لا تمثل
نسبه كبيره النسبه الاكبر يعني عشوائيه
بدرجه كبيره رايناها تحدث كثيرا داخل
المدارس مثلا في المدارس لا يوجد استهداف
لفعل معينه احد الطلبه فقط للجميع
همم المراعيين الحدث الاخيره الحدث في سان
فرانسيسكو همم كان يعني ال- ال- القاتل
والمقتولين كلهم عمال زراعه من اصول صينيه
كانت يعني مشكله همم مشكله حاله عمل يعني
مشكله بين العامل وبين ان الاداره
والزملاء فبالتالي النسبه الكبرى هي فيها
معدل عشوائيه عالي وهذا ما يخيف الناس
لانك لا تعرف متى سيحدث يعني شخص ما قريب
منك سواء قريب من مكان سكنك او مكان عملك
او مكان دراستك سينفجر ويبدا بقتل الجميع
هل هناك يعني حوامل محدده هل يمكن للقول
مثلا بانه همم هناك دور كبير لوسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي اليوم في نشر حاله من
من العنف والعنف المضاد حال من الكراهيه
للطرف الاخر داخل المجتمع علامه الامريكي
بالنسبه يعني
التواصل الاجتماعي وما شابه هي رفعت مستوى
العنف
العنصر سواء كان موجه ضد يعني فئه دينيه
او عرقيه او حتى ضد يعني المعارضه السياسي
في السياسيه ولكننا كما ذكرنا هذه ليست
النسبه الاكبر النسبه الاكبر هي العشوائيه
والعشوائيه ترتفع بسبب يعني شبه حصري اللي
هو السلاح اولا والصحه النفسيه ثانيه يعني
هناك ضعف في مستوى تقديم الصحه النفسيه
للفئات الاقل يعني الاقل قدره ماديه اضافه
الى سهوله الوصول السلاح يعني في مناطق
عديده في غالبيه امريكا يمكن الوصول
لاسلحه قتاليه يعني اسلحه مخصصه للجيوش
بسهوله كبيره يعني باي واحد يقدر يروح لاي
محل يشتري البندقيه يعني طبعا ليست اليه
ولكن بندقيه حربيه مخصصه
خلال ساعات واحيانا في بعض الاماكن عندما
يكونوا متشددين خلال الايام
دي مشكله كبيره شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه هذا
منوستن اا الباحث في شان الامريكي احمد
الحمدي